I can feel it the lords troll smile
warmly honors and today we shall see the
fabled beast of Balor I read and when we
do see him when we are close enough to
behold the stripes of his eyes we shall
slay the Beast
I will plunge my strike sword of Legend
deep into the heart of the monster know
what divine ears deceive me
Tom I've ever done do you intend to slay
the beast of Balor
what has the beast not been terrorizing
the villagers we met a Halfmoon ago it's
been eating their goats but that's what
it does carnival or it eats goats now
wait then the Lord said it ached in the
small do small was ago that mean it
should have been act well or you eat
about half a goat yourself in the two
days we were in town before
yeah well that goat didn't have a night
look I think there's been a terrible
misunderstanding here I brought this
fellowship together so that we might see
the Beast of Bala not kill it what you
mean not kill we're gonna trap it first
and force it to tell its secrets who I
really want to observe it from afar I
thought I might take some notes perhaps
sketch it for research
brilliant brilliant and then when we do
trap it will already know the answers to
its riddles hey riddles why why would he
tell us riddles it's an animal it just
eats and roots around and such but I'm
going to trap it I'll kill it
I'll do anything to on it then why would
you summon a warrior a battle dwarf and
a wood elf Archer then
I like you guys I thought it'd be fun
we're always fighting Dark Lord's and
saving the realm but never really have
an opportunity to just hang out we have
been walking walking non-stop for four
years you thought this was just a nature
stroll I'm a thirty four hundred year
old wizard this was honestly just like a
normal walk for me at one time I walk
for eight years to see a toe
what magic toad no just a normal toad
there blue spots but breathtaking you do
realize that I went on an entirely
different three-year mission to get this
sword just so I could plunge it into the
heart of the beast of Balor on this
mission I want to point out but nowhere
in these four years did I ever once
mentioned killing the Beast you assumed
an awful lot my brother died whilst
questing for the sword with his dying
breath he made me pledge to kill the
Beast in his name - what in seven years
of work dead brother only to kill the
Beast then what I don't know I assumed
it would be made of gold or that it
would be hoarding gold or somehow girl
would be involved why would an 800 get
with what is essentially a big fancy
bear that eats goats why would such an
animal have money hock turn to the Sun
the wood elf has returned
what news I discarded the beasts lair
instead a series of traps to ensnare the
beast upon its return
come on I had no intention of disturbing
its natural habitat what crawled up old
man win a spot Hey I have 400 years
younger than you human ears I'm only 29
in Alphaeus the sand you ain't gonna
believe this but apparently ran never
intended to kill the Beast de Bala he
just wanted us to look at him look at
will they tell the secrets see that's
what I thought
secrets or riddles or secret riddles of
how to get its gold but no he just
thought it would be neat it's the last
of its species now no one has observed
it in the wild and sensory you know if
you won't keep on killing all the
mystical Beast IV none left for your
grandchildren I could only hope to leave
the realm that's safe my grandchildren I
150 years old
Auggie's single this supposed to be a
bonding experience for Azure mean don't
you ever get tired of questing don't you
ever just want to see the realm without
killing everything I like killing yeah
we all like killing on we love it but I
think I know what's really going on here
look brand we can't wander the realm for
four plus years and not kill a mystical
beast at the end it's simply not done so
strike your deal we go i plunge nice
strike sort of legend even to the heart
of the Beast of mallow we collect
whatever gold may or may not result from
the slain and then we'll all go spend a
few weeks in elven realm drinking
enchanted ale and chasing a mortal tail
hey what do you say I don't come on the
Santa ho Q up with a sister big part
fine great onward then brothers glory
awaits glory and a scarves of enchanted
gold all around the realm on the rail
hey there we made this video with the
guys from a new comedy channel on
YouTube called the nether region now
we've known these guys for 20-plus years
and unlike us they are actual actors
with IMDB pages and experienced talent
and all that good they'll be doing all
sorts of sci-fi themed comedy over on
their Channel and we highly encourage
you to check that page out and if you
want to just go ahead and subscribe to
them because that's how much sway my
opinion holds with you then just click
here and might I also add that you have
excellent taste